to the church what's happening now my
main man steve burns in the house today
lee syed direct from how was the weekend
lee that's great tell them what you got
dumplings yeah we went to korea yeah he
goes [ __ ] dumplings
every now and then yeah
i haven't got korean barbecue yet but do
you haven't no you got to do it i heard
it's amazing amazing but there's always
lines like there's always that means
it's good but every one of them can't be
good there's a line outside of every one
of them down there because there's not
kosher
which one do you go to in korea chosen
chosen
that's the popular one it's kind of like
the high end it's it's i i think if
you're going to do it you do it right
right no i don't i want to do it but
have you watched bourdain's show yeah uh
it's the one he went to with david show
in koreatown the dumpling place yeah oh
so good so we've been there like five
times
and it has a b rating so you know it's
good yeah and they bring you the bonchon
the kimchi and stuff oh yeah i love that
but you've got to be within you know if
you have kimchi you got to be within
like a two mile radius of your house oh
i didn't know that the first time we
went we put it in the car
in the back because i was i'm a jew i
wanted to take it home
we went to a bar for our drinks for like
45 minutes came out the car smelled like
someone took a [ __ ] in it and i had no
idea that you took a [ __ ] in it
apparently that's why you don't bring
that [ __ ] home we have to throw it away
at a gas station [ __ ]
but we went to we went to versailles for
uh sangria and we had to throw in that
gas station right there in west l.a
because it just stuck with the drive up
back on the 405 with the windows open
you take that then you it's just it's
it's like spicy hot cabbage cabbages
it was cold out i thought like if i left
it in the trunk we left it in the trunk
not even the regular part of the car but
you eat that then you have sangrias
afterwards you might as well just start
the clock on your tummy yeah just like
any second it's going to go off oh no
it's great but then yeah we went we went
and it's always busy but it was that was
fun and then last night the mom made
tacos and
it was awesome
i'm dating a mexican girl so it's just
her mom
not a jewish mother i'm not losing his
[ __ ] mind steve yeah you're in love
yeah yeah yeah well it's been almost two
years
oh that's great yeah congrats been going
well let's go he likes messing with me
but it's fun
who doesn't need who doesn't enjoy like
messing with and your apartment's always
clean now because of her oh it was good
it would be if i let her in there but i
don't know i can't cleanse it he gets a
maid he gets once a month i have someone
come home he's got this from vietnam
she's got to come over and clean this
house oh i thought like the mexican girl
would leave and then all of a sudden the
mexican girl comes over to to clean it
up oh she would her mom totally would
her mom offered to do my laundry
that's very nice i can't that's old
school
but joey's worried and now i'm worried
that the mom wants to move in she does
what he does i don't know this [ __ ]
guy doesn't know that once he marries
the daughter you marry the family the
daughter's gonna say listen i can't
leave my mom by myself yeah yeah because
the cousin's automatically gonna meet a
guy yeah then they're gonna move
everybody in and she's gonna be right
there shadowing you
if she makes tacos if she makes tacos
like she made last night doesn't it oh
but it becomes something different once
they move in y'all learn spanish and
watch novellas with them and rub their
feet with [ __ ] i'm aware with that
santa claus juice last night we watched
the mexican version of the kid's voice
like the voice but it's for kids and
it's mexican people so like daddy yankee
was on and this yo this guy who was a
mariachi when he was a kid and they were
dancing the entire time and right after
that uh by like the biography of selena
came on and she was singing she was
singing while she was cleaning were you
sitting there throughout this whole
thing for part of it yeah jesus christ
he said this is why i give him a hard
time what am i supposed to do who says
thanks for the tacos pizza get the [ __ ]
out of here i'm done i'm out of here i
don't need somebody singing selena songs
that's bad luck
the woman that that like killed selena
right looks like the woman that
schwarzenegger banged and had the kid
with same ones don't you think it they
look
literally exactly the same
crazy little weird mexican lady was her
manager no it was uh it was a manager
who shot a wall kind of like the fan
group fan club yeah yeah she was
stealing money from the fan club
but the interesting is part of her uh
community service was to do house
cleaning at the [ __ ] schwartz vegas
schwartz vega gabriel stabbing boom and
skull baby are you [ __ ] crazy steve
burns that lady's doing time under the
[ __ ] jail and she she never said why
she did it i asked cause i thought she
was one of the ones that died in a plane
crash but apparently that's
um aaliyah so i just didn't i i'm not a
big that kind of music fan and she said
no her manager is black
i don't know who elizabeth that's what i
got to deal with you said i got there
selena he goes down to korea town
dumplings and jumps up and down and [ __ ]
no i don't know but how come she's never
said why she killed her like who
everyone stole the money then when she
got accused of it she shot it but she
had mental health [ __ ] problems
that's why she shot i think she shot her
in a yeah yeah they held her up in
corpus christi and truck
and they had a surrounding at some hotel
or something selena's like the mexican
elvis they just will not let this woman
go away
she's always every year there's like a
selena fest and all this [ __ ] and yeah
she was huge man she was about
in 94 you know listen
the sad thing is everybody's always
about
yeah to do that tupac was about right
celine was about you know but
uh the album was great and they shot it
in the process of the album being
popular what was that song uh i don't
know the slow jam not a bad jam it
wasn't bad
and then the movie they made the movie
with jennifer lopez
you know i remember uh howard stern made
comments about her
and and the big thing was howard stern
how to get secured at the mexican mafia
was yeah howard stern and [ __ ]
they were gonna shoot him james almost
was on his way to [ __ ] new york yeah
got a message i can't mess with selena
though you gotta be a little [ __ ]
careful next thing that we got to cut
down in our living room yeah making meth
and [ __ ] banging our wives
what the [ __ ] lee you didn't know but
anyway you had a nice time
but i actually had something that i was
thinking about that i wanted to ask you
guys so my brother called on
wednesday or thursday whenever i went to
see vicky pezza and we were talking and
he was saying how much money he's making
and i got i like [ __ ] my head a little
bit he wasn't doing it to be mean but we
just hadn't talked in a while
and like i started thinking of all these
things and how like i'm like a bad like
not a bad person but like i felt bad
about what i'm doing
and like the next day i was thinking
about like it's
him making money has no it has nothing
to do with me really and like i don't
like i was trying to think of like get
rid of quick schemes and like and how to
like start making a lot of more money
but i was just like it must happen a lot
with comics when
people are doing better than you and
making a lot more money and
how long did it take you to like not
freak out about it like to not get
really pissed off and
like think you're oh i'm gonna go back
to robbing people or whatever i knew
from the beginning i knew from the
beginning that all you could do was
worry about you
i knew from anything else i ever did
yeah when you're a comic you're you're
just golfing
you can't work yeah he's having a great
round he's a [ __ ] that you just you got
to concentrate on your game that's it
and you're always competing against
yourself that's the way i've always
viewed comedy because
that shit's gonna eat you alive
literally just gonna eat you a lot
there's always somebody who's doing
better than you there's always some new
guy that's gonna start to pop and the
flavors of the month they all go by the
wayside you just gotta keep doing your
own thing and keep working your ass off
and hopefully at the end of the day when
they bury you they see some dirt
underneath your fingernails and go oh
that guy worked his ass off that's why i
always look at it you know it's cliche
to say but it's like
i'm a little older than you and life is
like peaks and valleys you're gonna be
hot at times you're going to be cold at
times it's life you're going to have
good years yeah you're going to have a
[ __ ] bad you're going to have a
divorce something's going to happen you
know your mom passes your dad passes
something happens and you have peaks and
valleys but you keep going and i think
it's the same way with comedy when uh
you first came in i asked you about the
show yeah solomon's son which you
created and sold and
uh big ups to you a bad [ __ ]
move in the world of comedy most
importantly you
brought your friends in which meant the
world to me you you brought i would
watch the show when i was on the road on
a saturday and i'd see owen benjamin and
the black dude and i'd see how man i met
and i'd see all these guys and
usually comics get a little success and
they alienate themselves yeah but the
good ones
bring family in
to have that closeness on this set yeah
to watch your back plus to make it
[ __ ] funny your flavor yeah and
that's what you did so i give you all
the grace in the world but then
uh wavy
you know
in 97 96 a bunch of comics got shows do
you remember oh yeah yeah and it was
margaret cho because they all wanted to
duplicate come out it was margaret cho
greg geraldo and tom rhodes yeah they
threw three shows at him all three shows
failed if those comics would have put
their heads between their tails and said
well tim allen hasn't disappeared
they wouldn't have been here margaret
cho was doing better than ever yeah
todd whatever tom road just funnier
[ __ ] ever yeah and greg geraldo
rested rest in peace before he died he
was one of the top three [ __ ]
headliners in my world and like i agree
with you yeah so
for some people they [ __ ] fall
wayside this takes them aside oh i can't
deal with it for others they [ __ ]
scrap off they get a roseberry sandwich
or salt and pepper some potato salad and
they get right the [ __ ] back out there
and that's the best way to [ __ ] put
it that's the american way yeah you know
the people that you see that are in
therapy and on zoloft and whatever the
[ __ ] pills are that's because
something's triggered and they won't let
that [ __ ] go yeah it's here we
get it and we sympathize with you and we
understand you went through a rough
patch but there's a whole [ __ ] world
out there yeah there's a whole lot world
out there and so what so what there's a
guy that's funny in you bill burr is
hilarious yeah [ __ ] sebastian's
[ __ ] hilarious you're hilarious if i
went home and sat there
i gotta beat number three you're missing
the whole point of this [ __ ] yeah
you gotta be you that's why like one of
the things i learned when i was uh
at the comedy seller in new york city
seven years at the seller
you know you see everybody there it's
much like the store where
on any night chappelle's going to come
in chris rock's going to come in you
know seinfeld is going to come anybody's
going to come in there and kill it and
you might be after that guy and when i
was starting off i was always like oh
well i'm not as good as chappelle i'm
not good and the real the thing i
realized after seven years is the
audience doesn't give a [ __ ]
they're done they're gone they saw him
now what the [ __ ] are you gonna do
that's all that's all the audience cares
about i learned that it took a few years
to learn it because in your head you're
thinking oh i'm not at that level well
of course you're not but at some point
maybe you will be but all you can do is
your best when you're on there and give
them the taste of of who you are your
identity and just go from there so
i agree with you everything you're
saying but when you're younger
like i'm being 25
and getting a cough i was living in
colorado
i was making about six grand a month
selling cars i was taking six credits at
night you know
i had a dog i paid 450 a month rent
the car was given to me if i sold three
or four cars
i wasn't doing bad yeah i wasn't [ __ ]
doing bad
uh
did i want to test the roses i want
chick sucking my dick steve burns i want
to go to a bar and pay for everybody's
drinks that i want to be that guy yeah
we all do when you
you know and i used to have friends that
would call me for florida and go hey man
we threw away a hundred thousand dollars
last night like we let it on fire last
night what do you mean we're down here
remember bob galindo he has a stock guy
uh i came down he bought me five [ __ ]
thousand dollar suits and i'm living in
this house i'm selling stocks and i'm
swimming and i've been going holy [ __ ]
what do you make a month and the guy's
like 28 000 and i only work i don't work
fridays and saturdays and all this [ __ ]
and i'm
hanging up the phone and feeling like
you and going well but going you know
what i got my own thing going on here
and not being jealous and a year later
they all got arrested for penny stock
fraud and you know how to do 10 years
they lost their licenses and today
they're firemen on the you know they're
doing [ __ ] roofing work i see them
when i go home all those guys your
brother's a [ __ ] fitness guy okay
right unless you're [ __ ] jacqueline
you ain't making no [ __ ] money in
fitness he's a personal trainer making
12 000 a month i'm sure he's paying
somebody who's doing a thousand things
that [ __ ] don't last i wish him a lot of
[ __ ] luck in the world i mean i
didn't i wasn't mad at him no you're
like oh we we don't have a good
relationship but like he wasn't doing it
to be a jerk
but he was telling you what you should
be doing to make that type of money like
that a little bit like that and then
it's just he's my younger brother i'm
the older brother like and part of me
was i was like i should be making
more like i should be making more than
him
but you're right i also lose two blocks
from your mom he goes over three times a
week for dinner you follow what i'm
saying to you too doesn't he live close
to mommy yeah all right then so at least
you're out here sweating your balls out
by yourself what the [ __ ] does he know
about that
he's two blocks from mommy [ __ ] goes bad
he goes back to mommies you're out here
living with two mexicans [ __ ] goes bad
you're on the floor next to the cousin
and the [ __ ] the other guy who's not
around no more
right or wrong these people you know
totally yeah you cannot ever worry in
your life
what somebody's doing you cannot worry
about it in your life it should inspire
you
especially when somebody close to you
and they're a good person yeah and
something good happens and you're like
wow that means i got a [ __ ] chance
yeah i got a chance yeah no and i hope
he does well because he's worked on for
years when you see [ __ ] people on tv
that i know you don't want a name to the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you're like this
[ __ ] idiot's making a living
can you imagine what i do if i get a pen
paper and a piece of paper yeah you know
if i stop drinking get a piece of paper
and that's how
uh tim in my world that's how he became
confident we were reflecting through the
channels one day and we saw some [ __ ]
idiot yeah jokes with a balloon in his
head and we saw him again and then we
saw another stand-up show and then one
day you go you know what to yourself you
go you know what i'm funny in that
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and then some guy at
work
while you're
driving a limo or whatever goes you're a
funny guy that matches both thoughts
together i'm funny in that [ __ ] now you
have the fear of getting on stage for a
year or it took me a couple [ __ ]
years to get on stage after that i i
determined i was funny on that [ __ ] i
saw right and my buddy told me i was
funny and all those [ __ ] it took me a
year you know but that's it it should
inspire you yeah it inspires you when
somebody goes i wrote a book and you're
like this guy has a hard time [ __ ]
waking up
yeah i mean when people talk
say those things to you
you have one or two routes you you let
it eat you up and you you give in to
that negativity or you use it as fuel
you go you know what [ __ ] it i'm going
to blow it out now so that that's you
know you can see this guy's making 12
grand doing jumping jacks can you
imagine
you imagine with the damage i could
[ __ ] do yeah that's how you have to
look at things and that's inspiration
sometimes yeah that's motivation for me
it is
for me it is you know i don't
the worst thing you know when you saw
that 50 cent soul [ __ ] vitamin water
and got 80 million dollars yeah how bad
did you [ __ ] feel you've been
drinking kool-aid for 2 000 years you
never figured out the vitamin c and that
[ __ ] yeah how dumb do we [ __ ]
feel it's american ingenuity he said you
know what why am i carrying vitamin c
and water or my multivitamins let me put
it in the [ __ ] yeah and sell it
oh how bad do you feel do i hate 50
cents [ __ ] no yeah thankfully thank god
you paid attention when they make
kool-aid we didn't do dick
we just were pissed because we didn't
have enough sugar in that [ __ ]
all right
yeah
that's this is life it's a beautiful
[ __ ] thing
yeah that's why you want to put a if you
want it to be yes and even if you don't
sometimes yeah i know a lot of people
who are rich or miserable [ __ ]
exactly yeah that's scumbag
[ __ ] but that's the way it is
i'll tell you something right now i was
i had the baby this morning
i got up at three in the morning my wife
is puking she gets migraines she won't
[ __ ] go to acupuncture she won't get
it fixed but you know all right you got
a [ __ ] migraine so i get up this
morning you know what i'm not gonna go
to 9 30 jiu jitsu right i got a podcast
at 12 with steve burns what i'm going to
do is i'm going to take the baby so you
can relax
all right i took the baby and i wasn't
mad or anything i took the baby and i
put her in a stroller i got a ball and a
bat yeah and some water because she
wants to give her milk don't give her
[ __ ] milk it's sunny on her stomach
will curdle give her water like the
communist
i took some [ __ ] water i froze the
night before that's the worst thing you
could do is get milk when they're
outside
i never thought about that that's right
yeah [ __ ] water what are you gonna do
it's 90 degrees in sunny l.a you give me
your [ __ ] milk
so i take the kids to north hollywood
and i give her the bat and i'm walking
back you know the birds are at the sun
it's 10 to 10 in the [ __ ] morning
and i'm gonna say to myself what would
make me happy than this at this point
yeah there's nothing not a tv show not a
blow job not a pound to blow not living
in colombia yeah not jumping up a
parachute this is it this is
right now i'm not even happier i don't
even give a [ __ ] about my comedy career
anymore yeah because i'm being i'm a man
it took me
[ __ ] years steve burns to be a man
yeah finally get together this is what i
need to do pay bills and i had the
concept in my heart in my head i just
never put them together right you're
always too crazy doing something else
and i always talking forward comics or
actors or writers what men and for the
first time i feel like a man yeah this
is what i'm doing i'm supporting a
family they're happy
they're all leaving without me which is
perfect that means you're doing even
better than what you think yeah you
could put somebody on a plane and go
don't worry about nothing take an extra
deuce get some [ __ ] lemonade at the
airport
it's a good airport chicago they've got
tons of [ __ ] to eat but yeah what i'm
saying like yeah yeah yeah i'm sure you
had that when you uh
you know what
after you hit 35 you know that you gotta
have a million dollars and still be a
[ __ ] the happiest times i've had was
when i had eight dollars in my atm oh by
far yeah the greatest
i think like the greatest times i had as
a comic was when i was starting like
you romanticize everything when it's
when it's all a reality when you're
headlining when you're doing an hour
when it's fun
but i don't know like
driving around military towns
18 years ago
sleeping in my saturn because i couldn't
afford a hotel room looking up at the
stars going it's going to get better
than this this is great i'm i mean i'm
i'm making a living quote-unquote doing
comedy right now and i was barely hand
them out i was sneaking on college
campuses to take showers in the gyms
and just going around i was like this
was exciting to me because i was doing
comedy so
yeah those are the happiest times and
then it's still great doing comedy i
love doing it
it's not a job to me at all but i agree
with you
thinking back to those years but
you take all that and seeing a kid like
my daughter when she laughs i'm like
that's the greatest laugh i've ever
heard i've heard a lot of laughs 18
years but that's the laugh i want i love
that laugh so
it's always those little things now the
the little things are what makes you
happy and you started in new york first
time you ever got on stage well it's
much like what you were talking about i
i
i finished college in ohio i went to
kent state and my parents my father's
from new york city jack lambert yeah
exactly oh [ __ ] james harrison
so my dad grew up in new york city got
transferred to new to pittsburgh uh
working for the yellow pages so
then he go then he went back to new york
city when i was in college and i said
can i crash in the couch for like two or
three months experience the city you're
dead my dad my mom yeah so they said of
course so i finished college i literally
graduated got my diploma got in a car
drove to new york city
i said i got in at like nine in the
morning i said i'm not coming home till
i get a job i started on on 96th street
and broadway and i walked all the way
down to 50th and broadway took all day i
got the 50th and broadway i walked into
caroline's comedy club the manager was
there i'm like i'm looking for a job
he's like what do you want to do i said
i'll do anything he said come back
tomorrow fill this out and i started
sweeping the floor answering the phones
and i saw a bunch of comics i thought
i'm better than that i i think i could
do that so that's exactly what happened
and and it took me four months to work
up the nerve and i went to stand up new
york on the upper west side and tried
out for the first time and i came off
stage and i was like emotional and my
brother came out he goes why are you
crying i'm like i'm gonna do that the
rest of my life i don't give a [ __ ] if i
ever make a dime i will do that
the rest of my life so that's how it
started
you
you know when you said that story about
sneaking into colleges i remember
[ __ ] being excited to feature oh yeah
i was gonna i was gonna feature not
really feature it was a one-man
uh headliner he did like an hour 20.
yeah it was going to be like the mc
slash feature yeah and i'm getting in my
car and
having an ashtray filled with quarters
having like eight joints my clothes
maybe 20 bucks you know yeah b210 from
colorado and i knew in two tanks i'd be
it was like a 2 000 miles to the gallon
yeah
i've been pulling into michigan
four dollars i already ate two subway
veggies and cheeses
i can't even look at another [ __ ]
veggie and cheese yeah
you know if i add up the change in the
four bucks i probably got 16
there's nothing there for a hotel you
know yeah pull up
and i remember going into the town and
going i'm here and they're like
it's wednesday you don't start till
thursday and going
oh [ __ ] yeah what am i gonna do and
they're like well we don't know but we
can't get your hotel to tomorrow not
having a dime and going wow nobody turns
the car around
yeah you find the holiday inn you parked
back there and you uh get the sweatshirt
on and you get the sweatshirt
everything in that [ __ ] car yeah i
had music i had
rolling papers i had radiator cleaner i
had basketball i had a [ __ ] football
in that car that car became at your
house my house yeah and going to places
and going this is great driving home
like i had i had i have an older
daughter yeah in those days i used to
get her on sundays and i would finish in
boise idaho yeah at midnight
just get in my car and drive 10 hours
straight like pull over to take a nap
and you ever do that pull over to take a
nap and you turn the lights off and you
leave the car running and you wake up
and you think like you fell asleep
you don't know what [ __ ] fear is yeah
you know
and you think all those times and
wow
wow yeah but all that matters is
you know even nowadays people you know
uh it's such an easy job it's like the
other 23 hours kind of suck the hour
you're on stage is why you do comedy
that's the best part and so even when
you're sleeping in a car it's like you
get off after that 15 minutes when
you're starting off for 10 minutes at
host and you're like that was [ __ ]
great it's just so euphoric it's that
that to me was like the best drug so i
never got into drugs never got you know
i i drank i drink whiskey you know
that's my thing but i was always like
nothing will top that that's the best
and you worked at caroline's for how
long i worked there for about a year and
then i ended up getting fired because i
i was roommates with this girl who one
of the managers was trying to bang and
he was jealous and he just said you're
you're done here and i'm like what are
you talking about and he said get the
[ __ ] out and so i i got fired basically
because this guy wanted to bang my
roommate but for me it was a blessing
because then i i went even harder in on
stand-up and i worked at a greek
restaurant on 72nd and columbus called
the ag and until like maybe six more
months and then i just i was emceeing
and making a living doing stand-up so it
took about like a few months
but i i was knee-deep in it i just loved
it that's the only way to get you know i
tell people all the time when you get
into comedy i want you to think about it
yeah i really want you to think about it
because
as a hobby yeah you could be a hobbyist
and go to your open mic and do it twice
a week yeah but once like it took me
four years to decide that i was going
for it like three years of [ __ ]
around and having day jobs yeah telling
people i was a stand-up and really
jerking myself off yeah i was going to
new york i went back to new york i did
it for about nine months and i saw that
[ __ ] circus yeah and now i compared
that circus to where i was at in denver
which made it seem you know in denver i
could do
15 spots a month i didn't live in that
circus right in new york i could do 90
spots a month but i was in a [ __ ]
circus i had to have a day job
yeah i drove a limo i didn't [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] yeah so i went back to
colorado i simplified it and that's why
i developed and i went you know
once you start i used to go to wyoming
riverton wyoming yeah you know uh the
other one some of the best chinese food
yeah it wasn't [ __ ] uh
the place in wyoming on friday shrimp
and lobster sauce holy [ __ ]
and you drive up and it'd be all new
yorkers like lost new york in wyoming
and wyoming what would they do out there
to retire they did for a lot of lives
but this place cooked new york style
chinese food on fridays yeah and they
probably had like 12 tables and you'd
have to go like 11 and just be a line
yeah it was all new yorkers you know new
yorkers are like thank god for this
[ __ ] place they didn't have an egg
roll they had like shrimp and garlic
sauce had nice pork fried rice yeah but
i drive from boulder
to i can't remember what part of wyoming
it was it was like an hour ten it wasn't
but that's what i mean you gotta love
what you're doing when you drive 10 or
12 hours i mean nobody does that on on a
whim or just i kind of like it no you
love stand-up when you're driving i
remember i
i i took gigs i looked back and i'm like
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] but i left new york
city i rented a car
and actually my dad rented the car for
me because i wasn't old enough he had to
be 25.
rented the car for me i drove like 10 or
12 hours to johnson city tennessee
to go in mc for the weekend and drive
the car back up literally to do
10 minutes friday 10 minutes saturday
and then go back up because i was like
well this is how i get stage time that's
all i do i lost money i lost money on it
but i didn't give up but she didn't give
a [ __ ] it was like this is the best
it's part of i'm on the road i wasn't on
the road there's people that would think
you and i are crazy like when you tell
them that story like what you did what
listen my uncle runs that print shop
over on fifth street go see him you're a
little [ __ ] confused okay go see him
it's union you get benefits yeah after
30 days you get insurance it's nice you
gotta drive a car to [ __ ]
johnson city [ __ ] to lose money but
yeah this i drove
i rented a car from national rent-a-car
another forget it and [ __ ] drove 16
hours to phoenix to showcase for
knuckleheads
wow just to get in the loop
in the car when you get there the guy's
like where you standing my car no no no
no
we have a hotel everything worked out
yeah you know they bought breakfast i
got back in drove 16 my 16 hours they
gave me a week in minneapolis as an
emcee and a week in
phoenix and i got a call like a month
later the clubs were out of business oh
but but you did it
but sometimes when i go pick up a check
like sometimes when i work on a movie
and we catch them sleeping and you go
pick up your check
and it's a lot bigger than what you
thought yeah you think of that time
that's what i think is to justify it
yeah this is for that time i didn't have
money i didn't send child support so i
could rent a car for 150
as an investment i lost money but i got
it back 10 years it's this [ __ ] check
i just got yeah because what i do i went
there the two lines and i sat on the
table and they [ __ ] craft
whatever the [ __ ] all day that's how i
look at it sometimes i'm like ooh and i
actually think of the job
like new year's for sarah and i [ __ ]
12 shows for 600 bucks yeah new year's
it's 50 a show i did that yeah and i
paid 400 for the plane ticket so i ended
up losing
you know i ended up making 200 [ __ ]
dollars yeah but i worked new years you
know and i did six show or 12 shows and
you get your craft going and yeah so a
lot of people just don't understand that
type of investment
yeah it's not only the investment but
it's also you're happy like they might
have the security but you're in a
cubicle you're [ __ ] miserable you go
back you kick the cat you yell the kids
i every day i'm like this is [ __ ]
awesome i tell jokes for a living
and i come home i have a house it's like
i don't know to me there's there's days
where i i sit in my backyard i'm like i
can't believe this is all this is
[ __ ] amazing you know one of the
worst things in life as a man or a woman
of being young is when you
make a discovery
when you [ __ ] just
think of something go wow you know
and it's the feeling when you want to do
stand up when you
and i shouldn't say stand up when you
want to play the guitar let's say you
wake up tomorrow and you want to be a
[ __ ] magician and once you're doing
your little magic trick at the canyon
club on friday nights at seven for kids
yeah and we're just looking at as a
goofy way whatever i'm not here to make
fun of anybody i'm just saying that
[ __ ] it becomes so hard to have a day
job yeah
because it puts everything into
perspective like once your life gets put
into perspective it's the scariest thing
in the world because it becomes a do or
die situation yeah like i would have
people call me go hey man i'm gonna pay
you a thousand bucks a week come down
here wash cars
drive the people around and i go i don't
think so yeah
why not because i gotta work till eight
the open mic at rosie's
a 7 30 sign up like i wouldn't take a
job because of a half hour overlapping
but in the back of my mind i didn't take
a job because i wanted to be a stand-up
i wanted to see what it [ __ ] became i
wanted to see what you had to do yeah i
thought if i kept the job that would be
the [ __ ] easy way out maybe go
[ __ ] keep a job yeah i like walking
without a net that's what gets me
[ __ ] alive sometimes and i turn down
oh my god so like after i decide to
become a comic that's where all those
jobs started coming in yeah that i
wanted
like some place offered me a service
manager like starting at 40 plus
commission and you know you can make 80
000 after bonuses and i'm going
can i still do comedy though
a month it was a long month i was like
you know all these jobs i wanted
and that's how fate works now that i
found what i really love and what i
really want to [ __ ] do now all the
[ __ ] jobs that i really was looking
for started coming to test my
commitment and i was like [ __ ] it i'll
live in the car yeah
i'll live in a car i'll give up my
apartment i'll have a pager
i gave up everything yeah you know i
gave up tv when i first met roger and
they were like he's on news radio
all right what channels are they
like no
it's a [ __ ] tv show you know that's
what the commitment level is i didn't
know what a wedding was
yeah your friend that's the reason why i
became a comic so i wouldn't have to go
to [ __ ] weddings on saturday now
whether you have a wedding or whether i
have that date or not i'm not coming to
your wedding yeah i sent you an envelope
yeah i'll put 200 300 in there but you
know
that's a comic when when comics call me
now and they go things aren't going
right for me all right what are you
doing this weekend well my mother's
coming to town
your mother shouldn't be coming to town
jack yeah you know tyler eating
breakfast with it one day but we do
comedy here yeah we do comedy everybody
wants to [ __ ] die everybody wants to
go to heaven but nobody wants to die i
died yeah i put you know you died you
walked around new york city drove a
[ __ ] car but then we've seen the
people that you said that come here they
go to montreal they get six hundred
thousand dollars they go to the comedy
store they want to bump you they say
[ __ ] you and then one day
you don't see them normal
yeah it's a marathon
that you know we're guys like us are in
it for the long haul you're doing it for
the right reason because you love
stand-up and that's what i always
thought i was like you know what ebbs
and flows ups and downs doesn't matter
at the end of the day it's a body of
work that you got to create and
just be a [ __ ] killer that's it
that's what i try to do
you know sullivan's son how did that
come up
i was literally working my ass off on
the road and i just thought i'm just
gonna bang out these specials our
specials be a great road comic i don't
care uh moved to chicago left l.a never
got auditions any audition i was never
asian enough
never white enough yeah just i'm i'm
this weird weird kind of and your
father's new york city irish my dad's
yeah and old school irish the bronx
those [ __ ] uh stuyvesant town
oh where he he grew up so
uh and
yeah he's irish
generation uh yeah second generation and
my you know he what a weird clan they
are you gotta love them most guys irish
city yeah i love those savages i love
them and they all served so that's why
he met my mother over in korea so he
served uh you know army
did that for a while uh just a guy
that's like grew up alcoholic parents
did everything on his own kind of grew
up on his own in the city street smarts
older brothers but they were like 10
years older than him so he was never
really close to them so he kind of grew
up on his own and put himself through
college
army just one of the smartest guys i've
ever met he watches jeopardy he just
knows every question he can fix anything
he's like an old school great
american dad like when you think of a
man like an american man like that's my
dad he's just the best and
you know
just gave me everything coached all my
hockey teams just a great dude
uh
and
yeah so so i
that's how they met so i i basically i i
used to go hiking all the time uh up uh
this one can in bronson canyon with uh
vince vaughn so i i met him through a
metamed and a madden all those guys are
all pals so we used to go hiking all the
time and
one day vince just goes you know because
you're korean and irish you have so
limited opportunities you should write
something for yourself and i was like
well i never wrote anything he's like no
you can do it i go but i don't know he
goes you can do it that's literally the
conversation he just said you can do it
i think you can i believe you can do it
and i said okay so i bought all these
books
on television writing script writing
sitcoms whatever
for like three or four months on the
road i would finish my gigs and i'd go
to a diner or i'd go to my room and just
treat myself like i was in college i
just read and then another three months
i wrote the script and i turned it into
him he goes he goes what's this i go
this is the script i wrote it he goes oh
i can't believe you [ __ ] have this
conversation with so many friends they
never do it you actually did it so a
week later he called me and he said uh
this is pretty good let's uh let's let's
get to work on this thing so we did and
then within a year we filmed the pilot
which is really quick it doesn't happen
that quick it was what i found out
afterwards in which i'm starting to
learn now on my own but but i just took
matters in my own hands i wrote it i
never thought i'd be able to write
something
and it's so [ __ ] great this is how
[ __ ] up this town is hollywood is so
[ __ ] up okay i'll go on audition after
audition the very few i would get
nothing
i write a script
now i'm in charge right with
with the other eps and i'm sitting there
auditioning people and they're like what
do you think i'm like what do here's
what i think you don't even know if i
can do this i wrote it but i haven't
been in front of a camera yet and now
i'm judging people saying oh he's good
enough or she i don't know what's good i
don't know what's bad because i just
wrote the thing and i know if you put me
in front of a camera right now you
wouldn't cast me in my own show because
i've never been cast in anything
and then all of a sudden you're there on
warner brothers and
everything's the focal point of you're
the focal point of everything because
you're the star
and i was nervous as all i couldn't i
i went to warner brothers if you put up
one of those cameras like a blair witch
or like one of those uh
what are those scary paranormal activity
you just put it there
i was there friday saturday sunday we
taped on a on a sunday i believe i was
there friday saturday
and you could just see me go through my
blocking and doing my lines over and
over again i would have looked like a
crazy animal just doing this weird
pattern and everything because i was
just like i'm not gonna [ __ ] this up i
gotta i gotta nail this so it was scary
really [ __ ] scary knowing dan lawyer
christine ebersole brian doyle murray
jody long who was margaret cho's mom on
all american it's like i'm not holding
anybody up i gotta [ __ ] hit my mark
so i took it all very seriously but
that's kind of how it happened it's just
a a
a conversation from one of my best pals
who said i believe in you i think you
can do this you should give it a shot
and now
three years i worked on a show i wrote a
show i produced a show i started it
now i'm writing three other shows and i
just wrote a feature and so
you know all it takes is sometimes
somebody pointing you in another
direction going you're fantastic at this
but but maybe
develop one of your other traits that
come with being
a comic you know
you should think about writing something
for yourself and and here i am now it's
it's kind of crazy that that he believed
in me now was
sullivan and son autobiographical did
your parents have a bar together no they
didn't have a bar together but you know
essentially the foundation of the show
was pretty much what i was going
throughout my life in my life at the
time where
living out of a suitcase 50 weeks a year
i didn't stop i just ran the road
nonstop and i was like professionally
i'm doing great did the tonight show 10
times late night talk shows hour long's
great
money
saving it
personally i was a mess i was never
around my friends never saw my family
didn't have a girl it was just the worst
so i wrote a show about a guy
who who gives up the professional
aspirations he had in new york city to
go home to be with his friends and
family in pittsburgh because i didn't
have a home the holiday inn was my home
the marriott was my home a height was my
home
so i was just daydreaming what would i
love to do i'd love to go back to
pittsburgh be with my mom and dad be
with my my brother who i made a sister
on the show
be around all my pallies and uh and just
create a universe where it was like
daydreaming this is best case scenario
for me and any any every guy wants a bar
i think every guy wants to put a bar in
his man cave or in his basement i
thought that's what i'll do so that's
kind of the genesis of of sullivan and
so and that's how it happened that's
brilliant you know yeah and so steve
sullivan got what he wanted he got
personally to be happy and it's so funny
because when i did the pilot
i got married just before just as i was
writing it and my daughter was born the
day
of our table read so i was at five in
the morning i was at the hospital and
then at you know eight in the morning
i'm at the table read and she had just
been born prior to so
christine ebersole was like this is a
good sign for the show and it was we got
three great years out of it well nothing
to be [ __ ] ashamed yeah no no no
absolutely no deal i loved every second
of it every day was a blessing and i you
know i tried to get you on sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't dama he got
put through the ringer he almost did it
he couldn't do it at the last minute uh
but you know everybody crystal leslie
jones usually yeah julie was casting it
it was it was the best we had so many
friends uh gardell who i used to tour
with for years we toured we did this
jamison whiskey tour for two years we
lived out of our suitcases and just kind
of trying to sell the jamison name but
we went across the country back and
forth twice and there's a guy now he's
on mike and molly and so it was kind of
cool to literally be on one sound stage
he's on the other we'd go over we'd see
each other say hey and we're like
four years ago we were living over
suitcases shucking jamison and here we
are now in warner brothers it was it was
great but this is part of the dream
especially this comic dream because
what i liked about it was i'm not here
once i was going to college and i went
to prison i came out
and i really really tried steve byrne i
really tried to
because that's what i always wanted it
was like you i just wanted to be a
normal person with a normal job and have
the weekends off
and i tell you i did it yeah i had a
roofing i was a roofing estimator and i
liked it and i like the contact i like
getting in the truck in the morning and
but
then i had a problem
this is it yeah
this is it guys this is it so i'm 65.
yeah i'm 30 years old so in 35 years
joey was a great estimator he was a
great roofer he had a great roofing
company i got a watch
and i got a bad back and that's it and
that's a great american [ __ ] dream it
was a great dream for me at the time
coming where i was coming from yeah but
there was something missing there was
just something missing you know i think
the more i like i hear you talk i'm like
you know i'm receiving it and i'm
thinking you know you always personalize
things
i i think it's love
love is what it is ultimately because
when you see that girl you're going to
marry most you know there's a lot of
guys gals they go the minute i saw her i
knew it she's the one i love that girl i
don't even know how i don't know why i
love her i want to be with her that's
who i'm spending my life with people say
that all the time
i think the same thing with stand-up or
anything that you love doing your
profession you just something clicks and
you go i love that i'm doing that i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm in love with
i'm in love with you know when i was in
new york city i was in love with comedy
comedy was more
i love comedy more than girls
you know i would go out i try to meet
girls after the show but it's like yeah
i can't me i can't meet you for dinner
because i got five shows tonight you can
meet me at two in the morning definitely
if you're still out absolutely but till
then i'm seven days a week 365 days a
year for seven years in new york city i
worked thanksgiving christmas christmas
eve new year's eve i didn't give a [ __ ]
because i loved stand up and i still do
so i think love is what's the minute it
clicks for you you go i love that
it's amazing how my love has changed for
stand up
yeah like from 2019
to
2004 it was the love to get better to
figure this out to figure this puzzle
out right
and then i didn't like it for a while
it was it became the business came in
the business part i gotta argue for how
much money i'm gonna make
radio oh yeah then you have the business
part of it and it
i didn't like it the great eddie griffin
used to say we got into comedy so we
wouldn't have a day job
yeah but unfortunately that's that's
part of it that's part of it
so i just
and then i didn't like it for a while
and then i almost got out i was just
gonna do sets around town and you know
whatever just go up there and [ __ ]
around then this podcast thing started
you know you go out and it's weird
because the connection we have now
during the week we go out to towns and
then those people and they'll go hey man
let's do a steve burn episode and it
becomes one yeah and it's really nice to
meet these people so it makes me work
harder writes me being on top of my game
so the love has changed which i don't
know if it happens with a woman yeah it
does because i love my wife now more
that she has the baby yeah yeah i love
her more now now we're connected there's
something a little tighter than just
dating and just [ __ ] and just being
married now we're real it's it's been
solidified you know
so i think that yeah you're right the
love does grow i love it
yeah
i absolutely love every second of it but
i agree with you the love does change
there's ebbs and flows i almost it's
funny when you talk i almost quit stand
up maybe going into my third season of
sullivan and son
you know here we are we're on tbs we're
a summer show we don't get the accolades
we don't get the write-ups
i never got invited on a late night talk
show to talk about the show
i my manager left
comedy um
i basically had no manager i had just
filmed a third hour special
and i tried to meet with a lot of
management agent nobody would even take
a meeting with me and here i am
producing and starring in my own
television show got an hour nobody will
meet with me
um i can't get on anything other than
what i'm doing
and i came to a point where i was so
bent up and banged up i'm like why am i
giving all this love and investment in a
stand-up comedy and seems like nobody
gives a [ __ ] so [ __ ] it um maybe i'm
just done with it i talked to my wife
and i stopped going to the store for a
little bit i would just go on the road
to make the money to to pay the rent and
then
i just i don't know there was something
that just clicked and i i i wrote a joke
and i said that's why i do it because i
wrote this joke called uh
about being a champion and i wrote it
literally just before i filmed the
special
and
and i i was like that's the best joke i
ever wrote in my life and that's why i
got into standby in the first place and
so [ __ ] it if people like it they like
it if they don't they don't i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm happy i'm happy doing this
and so
write your ass off and so i finished the
special
done
and then i'm starting to write this
fourth one now i'm in the middle of it
but
that to me was like a pivotal moment
where for some reason just almost like
sometimes people go i don't know how i
wrote the song it just came like that
joke just kind of came to me and maybe
that's somebody upstairs tapping on the
shoulder going don't get too down
you know you you know you love it it's
still there for you have fun with it and
it reinvigorated my my passion for it
you know what i do when i'm feeling
weird about it yeah i go to the store
yeah an hour early
and i sit in the back yeah i shot my
mouth
and i'm sitting next to nobody i try to
hide and i watch it yeah and once i
start laughing again that's it yeah
i should do that that's a good i gotta
[ __ ] get up there yeah i come up to
you like two more than you and you're
like you [ __ ] i'm sitting back
here now like a [ __ ] egg yeah what's
up blue you came out of your little coma
over there yeah i'm good it's
last week steve we talked about i had a
big tax bill and i got like 60 70 emails
this week
and it's amazing how people love other
stuff like this guy wrote me he was a
big executive for nike and he quit
he lives in dallas and he's opening an
exotic pet resort with his friend
he's making like fifty thousand dollars
less a year but he loves it it was it
was crazy to get those emails there's a
lot of people going through it and it
was it was cool to hear that from people
you know society
puts you in a mind life puts you in a
mind sometimes yeah and those are the
people that you go to some place
and after you do your business you go
boy that person hates their job oh oh
every anywhere go anywhere people
[ __ ] hate it hate their job
can i use your bathroom
one more time put a little little tony
bennett while my main man goes take a
little wee-wee there i've been drinking
like a gallon of water a day now because
my wife's getting me on it and i'm like
[ __ ] this i gotta piss all the time bro
i do i go through this [ __ ] at night
where's the tony bennett [ __ ]
it's a beautiful day to be alive go out
there grab me
around
you see like i deal with stuff from the
beginning please
what happened nearly i was trying to
change cameras sorry
hi
what's the matter [ __ ] though
huh nothing doesn't matter
what are you sitting acting like i'm a
blue
because i probably had like 300
milligrams oh yeah yeah
i gave you a hundred feet
maybe a hundred [ __ ] milligrams you
know whatever
buzz company
it's monday
wait and see
what's up lisa at your little [ __ ]
red bastard nothing i'm feeling good
sure i know you're feeling good like
2 000 milligrams of these edibles i know
that's what i said you feel [ __ ]
tremendous here
sorry about that that that was just i
was i was getting to a breaking point i
was like oh
something that's gonna happen sometimes
you just gotta [ __ ] pee man yeah hey
man
i gotta pee all last night i got up only
once
yeah usually i go out i drink water
you go to the common store you grab a
water you're gonna laugh at you grab a
water oh yeah yeah yeah you're home and
you want to unwind and maybe make some
notes so what do you do you make a decaf
and you don't know how many ounces that
is but you got about [ __ ] 48 ounces
floating in your [ __ ] biscuit and
your piss hoes
and the next thing you know you go to
bed you're sleeping tight yeah
these things how many of these things 16
16 yeah so it's 32 plus the [ __ ] 8
ounce coffee that's 40. you got 40 on
your kidney and your whatever your pia
calculator only breaks out in five ounce
pisses so that means you got to pee
[ __ ] eight times in [ __ ] six hours
so nobody sleeps so that's what happens
you get start looking forward to getting
older once you hit like 44 your eyesight
just goes to the point where you can't
see a dollar bill when you get off stage
yeah it's dark you can't [ __ ] see you
go from that light
all of a sudden you're looking for the
stairs like that old guy on the [ __ ]
escalator it's a [ __ ] nightmare
and then you gotta pee
you gotta pee all the time you gotta pee
and once and you always gotta pee as
soon as you get on the 101 and there's
traffic
then you gotta pee and i will pee any
when i pee today
i peed somewhere today with the baby
yeah she was on the swing and i just
went home and took my little peanut out
by the [ __ ] garbage can
i was making believe i was looking at a
water something i just peed i got a
[ __ ] pee man yeah for breakfast you
drink water yeah i drink water with the
[ __ ] pills and the breakfast so
the [ __ ] lee everything all right yeah
you little pigment
yeah what was last week uh
what's that what was the shirt i was
wearing last week oh the whatever the
sugar night t-shirt yeah one of those
sugar night t-shirts the v-cut with the
t-shirt underneath that's a sharp
t-shirt that's a [ __ ] great out
beetles you know yeah love them it's
amazing nobody talks about the beatles
yesterday i was into the beatles and i
had to [ __ ] drive slow and get my
composure
i was i didn't grow up a beatle fan
it was pounded i grew up in a beatle
neighborhood yeah and they were all
waiting for the [ __ ] comeback yeah
john lennon got shot it was the saddest
and happiest day of my life because i
shut those [ __ ] up
it's over no more come back move on with
your life put on leg zeppelin they'll
cover this spread
it was amazing beetle fans were wait man
they gotta make it back i heard it i
remember i was a kid in that [ __ ] you
know when he got shot in 79 or 80 80
yeah 80 he got shot i was already
[ __ ] seven you don't want another
piece
a flying jew just to come down
no but that's how good the beatles are
that's i think it's how bad music sucks
today
music sucks so bad they you have classic
rock stations you have show stations
that play oldies because there isn't
good enough [ __ ] the i don't know i i
just think music today just was it the
beatles that like i heard on the radio
or something that they outsold like
like like six or seven major artists now
like beyonce ajc like they did the math
and the beatles sold more than like six
or seven major people yeah was that them
i don't know if that's a major it was a
different game there was no downloads
there was no videos it was straight-up
gangster either you bought the [ __ ]
arm or you didn't how many arms did
yourselves be burnt how many well i got
18 downloads and 16 solid arms and 72
cds no how many [ __ ] arms did you
sell all right just give me the [ __ ]
bottom line nobody had eight tracks
albums you [ __ ]
see now they rob you because now you did
13 downloads and you sold eight hard
copies and 16 downloads internationally
yeah which means they tax you at dollars
too the chinese they don't [ __ ] around
they grab you right in the air you know
what i'm saying just like a psychic i
mean there were so many now i i think
yeah the beatles probably [ __ ] killed
it yeah you know the beat
what the young general they have to have
like a nut like they had roots when i
was a young kid like just when you were
starting like i don't know about black
people they put roots on tv you were
like okay yeah they're all right they
ain't that bad you know what i'm saying
but now they have to do the same for
beatles because the last four
generations really have no idea what
happened really have no idea about that
shirt can you straighten up for a second
lee
okay so this is supposed to be paul
mccartney what i'm on i'm supposed to be
paul mccartney's funeral watch your
hands steve burn
see how that's supposed to be paul
mccartney's funeral you see the p under
the beatles that p was for paul
mccartney they said that was a double in
this t-shirt on his album cover so
nobody really knew if paul was dead yeah
they were playing a trick on america
like this kim kardashian [ __ ] that
wouldn't fly back then yeah this was all
they were you know when they walked
across abbey road he was barefoot yeah
there's so many things that they were
throwing to [ __ ] with people nobody had
ever [ __ ] with people before yeah that
was the beatles and that's why and all
of a sudden you put on like rubber soul
and you're like you know what i've never
done drugs but i'm thinking about it i
feel like i just did it yeah right
rubber soul you're like i don't know man
but they did this album because they
they didn't want to tour anymore so they
said [ __ ] we're just and they got
experimental they did and it was it was
inspired by brian wilson's uh pet sounds
because they heard what he was doing
they're like [ __ ] we gotta
you know so that's like that's like we
were talking about earlier you know you
can let other people get in your head or
whatever they listen to brian wilson
they go okay holy [ __ ] look what this
guy's doing so you use the fuel for fire
or you sit there and you [ __ ] and moan
about the guy what he's doing so
they said they used it to inspire them
and then they they create one of the
greatest rock and roll records ever
one thing about the beatles that has
always
that's taught me a lot about life taught
me about careers in life is that
i don't know how many albums they put
out i don't know what the number is 16 i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is
but you saw the evolution you saw the
evolution with led zeppelin you know
yeah as a comic
you want the same you know i listened to
my last cd two days ago it was [ __ ]
terrible
that is the worst cd of all time
[ __ ] with asthma and it's just
horrifically yeah
you know and you and i'm sure all comics
listen to their second cd and go
how do i find the way to get all of them
back
yeah like how do i get them all back
like i don't ever want this cd out
because we evolve i'm sure that if you
go to paul mccartney and go
tell me the truth about sergeant peppers
i [ __ ] hate the third song you're
like what yeah you know so
that's what i liked about the beatles
that
and it answers the question we have no
matter what people the beatles listen
the beatles were around
when people were throwing heat they went
up against the stones
the doors
janice joplin you know the tail end with
zeppelin jimi hendrix i mean guys
there's a different market for music you
had a [ __ ] come out you listened to
an album from 1971 and you buy an album
today and go okay
let's you're a nice guy steve brown
you're not gonna criticize nobody you're
a sweetie yeah how many good songs are
now and you're like seriously one
how about that led zeppelin now how many
are then you look me in the face and go
you know what i like hate songs five of
those [ __ ] are killers yeah
that was the level of competition the
who
yeah all those guys over there i'm not
even talking about here those guys were
over there just the brick banner eric
blant uh eric [ __ ] clapping with the
yard birds you know what what if paul
mccartney ran and go guys you better
listen to the new yard bird out we're
done no they're going to do what they're
going to do and guess what
you're going to do what you're when
you're making your thing are you going
no i'm going to take down steve byrne
with the sound no yeah you're being the
best joey d as you could be yeah you're
not thinking about steve burns but if
you make your work it's the people that
go after people well i'm gonna show that
[ __ ] you didn't show me dick
yeah because you were too worried about
me cox show you show you worry about
your [ __ ] self so i credit that is
the perfect answer to your question lee
these guys were going up against killers
you know that manager was probably well
pete best that was the manager's name no
no that was the job they replaced oh
god well his manager their manager died
i think
maybe like three or four years in
god i forget his name
it's uh brian epstein so you're a
business
big beetle guy yeah love the beatles i
love music in general i love everything
can i ask you a question whenever you
see yoko do you go god damn it [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
that kid is the worst they should just
shoot that [ __ ] i haven't listened to
his stuff oh no you don't
or her stuff it's as bad as her hers is
pretty brutal oh my god
and people go to like her things like
she has art exhibits still yeah she
throws like chinese food on the wall
people are like oh my god that egg roll
and she has like hers well now i sing
song for you you got to sit there and
put up through this [ __ ] misery
listen let me clean your house with one
for the small 200. well i will say i
thought the cool the cool thing and and
by the way when you go to like la jolla
you know that uh i forget what that that
street is it's like garnett street when
you come up there's that big mural of
john lennon right uh and i always saw it
i thought that's the [ __ ] coolest
thing cause there's a black and white
john lennon and there's they they put
the ladder up there and they wrote yes
and i know the story the story of why he
fell in love with her or why he thought
she was amazing is that he went to one
of her art exhibits and there was a
ladder that went all the way up to the
ceiling and from the ceiling was a
magnifying glass and you take the
magnifying glass and you hold it up and
there was something very small written
and it was just it just said yes and he
thought wow that's really nice that with
all the art shows that he's been going
to people were negative and angry
and here's somebody that just wrote
something very positive and it was very
simple and he thought this is a positive
person i want to be around this this
woman and that's that's how i fell in
love with her and i thought that was
kind of a cool story but other than that
i think she's [ __ ] god awful i agree
with everybody
okay you make me go up a ladder and say
yes i'm gonna kick you in the [ __ ]
head okay i can fall off i gotta sue
somebody
turning around [ __ ] you in the ladder
[ __ ] you yoco owner you [ __ ] sucker
i'm gonna go up a [ __ ] ladder john
leonard really one thing about j he
taught her he tortured all his women
that's why they [ __ ] hate torture
yeah he used to kick her around and [ __ ]
which
you know i think you know even when the
cops come after you beat joker like
we gotta go no we didn't see nothing she
found the stairs
i don't know you got a t-bone in the in
the freezer her last [ __ ] cassette we
would have kicked ourselves
lee what's happening what are you doing
the rest of the day today lee where you
going nowhere now
i have to recover from this you gotta go
to the gym i will at some point you're
gonna wear your little blue shirt no not
to the gym you wear that blue shirt to
the gym it's all over they're gonna
[ __ ] give you there's people who do
that at that gym oh they do yeah they
look [ __ ] they're crazy people they
wear shorts with that shirt there's this
crazy old guy who wears she's like
oh yeah colored socks with sneakers on i
see somebody with colored socks on that
is the toughest day of my life
i wear black socks at the gym oh no yeah
because you're harvey homo that's why
i'm talking about [ __ ] black socks
with gym sneakers and you go to the gym
you can't do that you can't do that see
in my school they send you home in case
you step on glass the ink goes into your
blood into your foot that's why
but just for [ __ ] gp i don't want you
around with the [ __ ] uh
there's this old italian dude who wears
like business like loafers and like pan
he looks like he came from the office
every day but he's like 90 just walks on
the treadmill all day how come every
time i do a podcast in the daytime this
guy wants to become johnny construction
you know if i come in the daytime to
hang out nothing there's no [ __ ] uh
there's no woodpecker i come here and do
a pack uh also he's
anyway don't get me started
let me give some shout outs and we'll
close this [ __ ] up and we'll ask you
some couple questions there let's get
the week started right with brandon the
roach
burbank 818 get well [ __ ] andre
atheist whatever your name is justin
delgado paul lynch
vincent espinoza
leon suarez david
cormetto and debt squad nashville and
the rest of you [ __ ] savages out
there
so let me ask you this so you got these
two scripts
now i'm going to be as honest i can with
you in the description you gave me a
sullivan son you're on to something yeah
you're wrong
so comedy could become a stepping stone
for you because you have imagination
that i thought that sullivan's son was
actually autobiographical like your
parents had a bar at some time in
cleveland where the [ __ ] you're from
yeah the relationships were definitely
there the relationships were absolutely
on point my mom is my mom on the show my
dad is my dad on the show dan lauria
embodied my father he's the all-american
[ __ ] dad that there's no
like when my dad pulled in the driveway
he's one of those like if you if you got
in trouble and you hear those that car
come in the drive you're like oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna get it
i'm scared of my dad i was scared of my
dad when i was growing up i love my dad
i look up to him but he had a presence
too where it's just like if you [ __ ]
up
you're gonna get it you know so
i think there's there like that
old-school kind of american guy i think
is kind of lost now it's like the dad's
always a [ __ ] idiot on all the
commercials dad can't operate this dad
can't figure out the computer dad can't
you know it's just i wasn't my dad my
dad could do anything and you know i'm
trying to be that as well for my
daughter and uh son upcoming son
expecting so
yeah dads are supposed to do a lot and
then mom's supposed to be [ __ ]
superheroes yeah the [ __ ] that a mama do
it's just uh
i see it sometimes especially now at
this age at the park and [ __ ] when i
take her i see what moms go through
mommy's got a [ __ ] rough goddamn job
dad's got a rough goddamn job too what
do you think lee
everybody's got a rough job everybody's
got a rough job so i'm saying look at
the shape of this [ __ ] guy well he
gave me like 300 milligrams i gave you
75. you're gonna give me a little
[ __ ] piece this is a six thousand
milligrams thought it was it was let's
show it to the camera now show them what
it is it's halfway there we're gonna eat
the rest of it the first five days of
april
this is april fool's week six thousand
milligrams that's what what happens to
your wake up like the like jim morrison
you [ __ ] die you're puking the tub
and [ __ ] like that what's your next plan
beside the three scripts and the movie
script uh just writing this i'm on the
road working on this fourth hour so you
go out every week
every week yeah because i i look at it
like a like a like you're training for a
marathon you got to run every day you
got to run a little bit so i got to get
up at least three
three nights a week so you get that on
the road so you know do the hour work on
the hour chisel the hour and every hour
i agree with you like you look back to
your last day like that wasn't that good
so i just want to try to make each one
better and better yeah that's what you
do that's how you i mean that's the
yeah i never really
honest to god i never looked at
i looked at comics for being funnier and
having good material
but i never got jealous of a comic doing
better than me because i knew it had
nothing to do
yeah with me i always was if i saw
somebody go oh [ __ ] i'm gonna have to go
home and write a little more now you
know yeah especially when you're at the
store
and you see people who write every day
and they bring different ideas every day
and like i said it's never made me
jealous if anything inspires you it's
inspired me yeah yeah like i see
sebastian now he he and i kind of came
to the store around the same time
the guy selling out theaters you know
he's popping up all over the place he's
got a big following he's on the tonight
show with fallon and i'm like [ __ ] i
remember when he was questioning things
and now here he is he's killing it and i
watch him on stage i'm like his voice is
so defined he knows exactly how to make
whatever it is he wants to talk about
funny because he knows how to construct
it coming out of his mouth he just knows
his voice so clear
and i see that i'm like [ __ ] i gotta get
to that and it's like you know you're
always gonna doubt yourself sometimes
but i'm like
i gotta work a little harder now because
i see i see what it takes to to pack in
a theater and sebastian's doing it so
you know there's always guys that are
going to come up that will provide that
impetus for you and sebastian for me is
is one of those guys burr was it for a
few years but i mean burr's killing it
now he's killing it sebastian uh
with me it's different because i saw
sebastian come in
as a young kid that didn't say two
[ __ ] words it was very polite yeah
he spoke under his breath
what the [ __ ] guys yeah come on oh i
want to know if you're going to go up
next yeah i'm going up [ __ ] next come
on
and i remember still going to audition
with him and pulling them in he was
talking to a bunch of guys that weren't
going to do [ __ ] to him in a group and i
pulled them in come on
and we booked it it was politically
incorrect mob week oh wow and we booked
like a thing with uh bill maher yeah we
couldn't touch him don't make eye
contact don't shake his hand yeah jesus
and i see sebastian now he's this
[ __ ] animal yeah when you're an
animal you're gonna get the tv shows all
these young guys
you know i met ahmed is
the love of my life he's he's a great
guy absolutely uh
i shot marin with him and i hadn't been
back to the store in six and a half
years and i walked in yeah with him and
at one point we were shooting and we
were giggling with taller mark and mark
went away and
i looked over at him and i met do you
think did you ever thought
12 or 13 years ago we were starving
outside the uh the union when it was
now god knows where the [ __ ] it is it's
it's
tacos yeah or something yeah union was
down from pink tacos not the one that's
the den
no no no no it's up more when they sell
those little [ __ ] hats
over by pink taco across the street up
more from the because the union ended up
becoming
what dane cook became a star
that's that spot
on the corner there what's the [ __ ]
about the factory no no no before it's
telling an irish name right yeah oh
dublin's dublin yeah yeah yeah yeah so
the union the comedy from the union when
it was it was a meta med and jay davis
oh this is before yeah i know it's
ahmedamed and the girl that your buddy
used to date
the uh
half black girl that was hot that's how
she got started in comedy when i met i
met yeah who who told you to write the
script
it was vince vaughn's exes from when he
was starving i think she's still around
i don't know black girl went to work for
an agent but she got the idea
because i remember that's when
the movie came out uh swinger swingers
yeah and the lure was that they were
going to be down there one night oh yeah
you're following me every girl in town
showed up vince vaughn was there he left
out the back door yeah but the allure
still became i remember sitting with our
metamed and having nick apollo and
[ __ ]
at the time you know this is 97 yeah
having nick the paul and paulie sugar
hey we want to come to your club we hear
there's a ton of [ __ ] there yeah
because they were all waiting
for [ __ ] vince vaughn to come back so
the place became this hot tuesday night
spot yeah and thank god the goodness of
my heart it used to be the first three
comics every week was me mike young
and josh wolfe i met ahmed took care of
us yeah every week he'd say listen
i got an agent in here now i got [ __ ]
you know uh every hitter was in there at
the time i forgot who they were yeah but
i will always give you guys a spot but
that's a matter that's not that i meant
that's why i wrote him in the show i
wrote ahmed in the show because i was
like i would never
even be writing a show if it wasn't for
a med i wouldn't be on warner brothers
if it wasn't for a met because ahmed
introduced ahmed got me kind of in the
commie store he's the one that brought
me in there and kept talking to tommy
and he's also the one that introduced me
to vince and brought me around and we
start we all started hanging out so
you know i met one of those guys it's
like you know you're my guy if i do
anything i got to have you a part of it
i met a man it's a weird story without
me and i met with type
at the union those years where you're
struggling and he would always call me
and say hey we'll get you 20 bucks
on top of the pink taco they used to do
comedy there too yeah i remember that
yeah
that way before the karaoke yeah no this
is when it was like a black club up
there they did comedy up there i mean i
met also booked that for like 15 bucks
tuesday at midnight and then something
happened yeah you know in those
beginning stages of comedy ahmed took it
somewhere else something happened
between him and i like it wasn't like an
argument or nothing
i had heard he wouldn't book me in
something and i got my feelings hurt
yeah so i started breaking his balls on
stage at the store yeah i would go up
and go who the [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with i meant i meant
and one sunday i was walking out of med
came up to me like a man unlike
everybody else who walks around in
hollywood yeah do you have a problem i
heard you goofing about me on stage like
that's a funny joke though yeah and we
both started laughing and i go i met i
thought you brushed me off how can you
do that to me
i'm your friend he goes it wasn't me it
was a guy that didn't want a bunch of
dirty comics in there yeah because i
never called this guy i didn't call this
guy either this guy so it wasn't
personal yeah and ever since then
i'll give blood for him in a minute i
don't get needles because
everybody else you know
in this town was around things yeah yeah
he came up to me as coked up and crazy
as i was and he called my [ __ ] yeah
today we're brothers i see a man i want
to kiss him because yeah out of the you
know you're going to find eight people
in l.a that have that type of uh it's
got a great heart and they have a car
that they what they tell you when they
put their hand down so when i did marin
with them like i said we were at the
crab service and one minute i looked and
go
did you ever think that we'd still be
here you know yeah i was 13 [ __ ]
years later
at the comedy store doing a tv show you
know so it's just uh
it's great to see you guys doing your
thing like i said i was a lot older than
you
i was with lee the day i got the call
to come into your show
and
i never cared about booking anything
i always
like when people call when people think
of you that means the world to me yeah
steve that meant the world to me that
day i always thought you were mad at me
from that night when i attacked the
the old manager at the store i got mad
at them because i didn't like how they
treated joe and i could care less about
that so yeah who gives a [ __ ]
so when they call and they said you have
an audition you you have no idea my
heart almost blew up because
for people to think of you and i made
them known i remember telling that the
father from the show various times i'm
like
he's doing a great thing by [ __ ]
bringing everybody in you know owen
benjamin another sweetheart yeah uh the
black dude kills me roy williams
kills me
so it's just
a lot of guys like you don't come along
man that take care of their own well i
hope to get another one on and i'll try
to get everybody on again i'll do i'll
do my best because you know after the
lesson you learned with this one you
want to do it again yeah yeah you have i
mean you have been
phenomenal i mean
90 of people that
show got canceled would have a story
would have i remember being hit 12 years
ago and i don't even know who this
person was didn't even know who this
person was i wanted the improv they came
up to me like hey man uh somebody's here
from some big time show on abc yeah i'm
a comic i don't know about [ __ ] tv
yeah and i didn't know who it was and i
guess they cancelled his show it was a
comic at the time i don't know i don't
remember they canceled the show and for
a spot he went up on stage and he goes
you know what [ __ ] nbc [ __ ] them that
punk and he was black they punk ass
white [ __ ] they can't give me an
answer they won't re-pick up my chef you
know what the [ __ ] it was
i saw you that night i did not know i
saw you excited for you
to be shooting your fourth season yeah
and you know like it got canceled and
then when i got in the car i felt like
that guy that asked the chubby chick if
she's pregnant but she's really not
it was like a chubby chick and you're
like how many months alone are you and
she's like i'm not pregnant oh
my
your attitude is great yeah cause cause
one show is not gonna define me you know
my body work like i said that's that's
what that's what's gonna define me my
all of it not just one thing so i
thought sullivan and son was great i had
a blast doing it but to me it's like
that's my college education in
television now i'm going to go off and
do something else so and you really want
to come back and pitch and do the hours
and start all of it yeah what were you
guys shooting six episodes of the season
and solomon said i was 10 10 then 13
and we were their highest rated tv show
on the network but but they're they're
moving in a different direction is what
i heard so you know they're i think
they're what they're trying to do is
more single cam we were multi-cam we
were more traditional and that was
always the
the goal to
pay homage to those multicams that i
grew up i love married with children i
love cheers i love all in the family i
love the jeffersons i love
family ties i love all those shows those
that those are the shows i grew up
watching so i wanted to do something
like that but a little more risque and
with a lot more uh edgy comedy which is
what we got away with with brian doyle
murray and all the racial stuff so it
was fun it was damn fun is part of what
you're considering is doing maybe doing
a show online i mean now that with all
the shows the community just went online
and
i don't know there must be more
opportunities than when the show started
yeah i think you know you know
absolutely entertainment's so fractured
nowadays that you gotta you gotta find
whatever vehicle you can to
give you the best opportunity to get
your story out so absolutely anybody
that's willing to give us a shot but but
i'll start chopping this stuff around
we'll see what happens well there's so
many we'll get something else on there's
so many different platforms now yeah if
abc don't want it now you can put a
couple curse words and put it on amazon
where you go to netflix
everybody's doing so much original
probably right yeah that uh and if not
[ __ ] it we'll do a web series out like
casa yeah like casa burn
you know that's the beauty about today
that nobody uh everybody could do you
could take this matter into your own
head on your own 15 years ago you went
to abc cbs
nbc they said no you brought it to fox
fox 22 yeah they told you to go [ __ ] you
that's it you went home and cried yeah
we're gonna sell it to cmt
yeah i want my pilot on cmt following
[ __ ] line dance class yeah that's
what i want to [ __ ] do
what's up man look at the shape of you
that's it no more [ __ ] gorilla
biscuits for you i don't believe you
steve burns
hey i love you to death i'm happy you
came it was an education love you dude
this is this is [ __ ] awesome to get
to hang out more than anything thank you
so much for thinking of me i uh i'm just
proud of you man that you uh didn't go
[ __ ]
you know [ __ ] tnt they
[ __ ] tbs if it wasn't for tbs i wouldn't
have three of the best years absolutely
by far they're the best they were great
to me i had a great time business is
business i don't take it personally and
you know when you're when you've done
this long enough it's like all right i
got to get back in the biz i got to open
up another shop that's it and you know
what man karma's going to take care of
you because you could took care of a lot
of people thank you but that means a lot
absolutely this is a blast thank you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you see these comics get
shows and then they'll hire comics and
you're like yeah
really well i don't know
when i'm around well okay good when your
show gets canceled for having a bad
[ __ ] comment go hang out with [ __ ]
your boy in l.a county jail yeah let me
close this [ __ ] up with the
sponsors and we'll get out of here are
you in a rush steve burns you have five
more minutes have you got a boogie with
noogie i understand
first off you take supplements steve
burns on it ain't [ __ ] around you
understand me yesterday i was feeling
lonely and depressed it was about three
in the afternoon i was a little stoned
the baby was sleeping i had nothing to
do
i took two shroom techs i went in front
of the house with two 35 pound
kettlebells and i went to work you
understand me i breathed a little heavy
i was a little huffing and puffing but i
made it and it was [ __ ] all because
of shroom tech sport right not immune
immune is when you mean for when you
want to be don't get sick when you don't
want to get ebola you take you
when you [ __ ] want more energy let's
say you want to give mom a stab and
let's say you want to walk up running
two [ __ ] uh
sports sport shroom text will put you on
point again you're like jerry what about
alpha brain [ __ ] we'll talk about shroom
tech today also that tea oil is
tremendous for smoothies the coconut oil
also the t-plus to get your strength up
and your reps and get more hair on your
chest you don't want to go to the beach
with [ __ ] patches missing from your
chest
like some transvestite went for the wing
anyway go to honor right now and press
in church boom get 10 off your next
order on it.com they're tremendous
whether it's the shroom tech and if you
want weights and kettlebells i can't get
you ten percent on that you're [ __ ]
you're on your own as far as minerals
and supplements are con
are concerned you're with uncle joey so
you're taking care of you get 10 percent
off go to on it one more time and press
in church
c-h-u-r-c-h for you [ __ ] people
that can't spell in your little moment
up there you go all right again you're
going joey what am i gonna do on good
friday i'm gonna sit there i can't
listen to music jesus got tortured no
i got the answer to your questions
irondragontv.com they're not [ __ ]
around you understand me kung fu you
like comfortable movies yeah this is
what i'm talking about a korean loves
kung fu everybody [ __ ] loves kung fu
movies you understand me
go to iron dragon tv right now they got
tremendous movies they got the blazing
temple it's on [ __ ] fire you
understand me they got
a bunch of [ __ ] they got what's the
other
movie series all the jackie chan back
before he was a stunt man this is some
deep [ __ ] right there they got new chuck
[ __ ] displays they got everything
they probably don't [ __ ] around do you
want to talk about what might not yet no
okay it's iron dragon look at the shape
of you what do you want to talk about
you haven't said three words you've been
sitting there like a monk with no
[ __ ] tongue relax now you want to be
charlie chan and talk and [ __ ] tell
me stories all of a sudden okay look at
the shape of you what are you gonna tell
them you're gonna [ __ ] up the whole
thing you put moose in your hand today i
don't have
anyway go to iron dragon tv right now
and get two free [ __ ] movies right
now today kung fu movies what's the code
joey joey j-o-e-y i'm telling you right
now if you want to get started in kung
fu movies you want to go to party you
want to be interesting anybody can talk
about [ __ ] bird man
drop blazing [ __ ] temple on them
watch all those gentiles look at you
like what the [ __ ] is he talking about
all right why be like the rest of these
[ __ ] mutts be original [ __ ]
talk about original kung fu movies all
right be special not like the rest of
these [ __ ] idiots anybody get a
tattoo with a feather and a [ __ ] hat
and talk about [ __ ] birdman whatever
the [ __ ] it is be original [ __ ]
it starts with irondragontv.com
right now preston joey two free movies
you're sitting there going joey i'm
sitting here by myself
i got nothing going on i want to smoke
some [ __ ] vapers i want to see the
devil nailed it life.com right now the
best vaper pen in the [ __ ] market you
can put your own stuff in there you can
grow it i don't care what you put in
there nail the life don't [ __ ] around
you understand me and right now they're
giving you twenty percent off go to
nathan life.com and press in joey diaz
boom you get 20 off if it's 50 that
means you get it for 40 for you dummies
out there go to nailed it live.com they
got other accessories they got the stick
to put the wax in they'll teach you how
to make meth they don't
they don't [ __ ] around all right go to
nails.com they'll help you out with your
problems you're sitting there like a
monster no ideas yeah joey what is it
the coverage joey joey diaz got 20 off
right you're sitting there you're
thinking
i love that you're sitting there saying
hey i'm sitting here you're sitting
there watching the kung fu movie you
just took two shroom tech sports and
you're smoking vapor you want the full
[ __ ] spectrum of debt do you
understand me that's where i come in
86.com 1200 guaranteed electronic pups
they go right to your [ __ ] brain they
calm you down you need to smoke cigars
the cigarettes oh joey but i smoke
cigarettes boo i got the answer for you
[ __ ] suckers 24 16 8-0 nicotine [ __ ]
e-pens they too again guaranteed 1200
[ __ ] hits but you know what take it
from don't believe me go to the page i'm
going to talk some [ __ ] walks look
at the jews go to hideysigs.com right
now pressing what in the box joey's
church joey's church and get 20 off so
if it's 20 you get it for [ __ ] 16. i
don't come here putting taxes on you i'm
here to break your balls i'm here
bringing your gifts you got on it 10 off
you got iron dragon tv you got two free
movies you got nailed their life i'm
giving you
of
20
and you got heavy six i'm giving you
twenty percent i could be a douche bag
and just give you ten but i go the extra
mile for you [ __ ] you
understand me thank you for watching the
show steve byrne who loves you more than
me love you pal no thank you nobody's
deep breath loves you like me talk suck
what are you gonna do now you're gonna
sit there like a patient's on the
monument let's go yeah we got more
edibles to eat okay
that's it guys so much
huh what you're not gonna close it up i
am i'm muting you guys so you guys can
talk no close it up i am all right then
close up the show okay
brought to you by honey yeah i was i was
gonna do that
this show is brought to you by honor.com
go to annette.com and use codewordchurch
to get that present up
i was just meeting you guys because i
was talking um i'm dragging tv use
codeword joey to get two free movies
go to hit e6 dot com and get twenty
percent off when he's covered joey's
church
and go to nailed it live dog comedy joey
diaz to get 20 off